An archaeologist enters the temple chamber.
It’s clear that whatever is inside, the
people who kept it did not want it found,
but there are no chests full of gold and jewels
or ancient artifacts piled in the corners.
In fact, the room is completely empty except
for one small statue on a pedestal.
Upon closer investigation, it is made of green
soapstone and appears to be carved into the
shape of a seated skeletal figure.
It seems harmless, and the archaeologist stares
at it - until he hears one of his colleagues
talking outside.
He turns back to answer them before looking
back at the statue.
Which is no longer on its pedestal.
The archaeologist panics, and calls for someone
else to come check this out.
But he only manages to get a few words out
about the statue’s mysterious absence, before
he starts feeling an odd tightness in his
chest.
He tries to head for the door, but everything
starts going dark.
He collapses to the floor, dying instantly.
And just as quickly, the mysterious green
statue reappears - this time located directly
on the chest of the deceased scientist, awaiting
its next viewer.
SCP-689, also known as the Haunter in the
Dark, was first discovered in the early 20th
century, as German explorers searched Indian
architectural sites for valuable artifacts.
The green soapstone statue, only thirty centimeters
in height, isn’t particularly light, but
it’s also not large or heavy enough to cause
any problems for those looking to take it.
Those who have studied it believe the skeletal
figure, which is seated with its hands clasped
over its knees, represents an ancient deity
of the underworld.
After its discovery, the statue’s location
was briefly unknown, but it was later obtained
by the United States’ Office of Strategic
Services from German hands after the end of
the Second World War.
And that’s when its dangerous properties
became clear for the first time.
While SCP-689 appears to be a standard inert
statue, this only holds true if it is being
watched by at least one person.
When it becomes dangerous is if it is in the
presence of a person who watches it, then
takes their eyes off the statue.
Thankfully, SCP-689’s anomalous effects
aren’t triggered by normal behavior like
blinking, but as soon as eye contact is fully
broken, like when someone looks away from
it completely, the statue will vanish.
It will then re-appear fifteen to twenty seconds
later - and bring with it a deadly curse.
Because each time SCP-689 vanishes, it takes
a life.
In under twenty seconds, one person who has
previously seen SCP-689 and broke eye contact
with it will die spontaneously.
The cause of death is always some sort of
natural cause, but it ranges from mundane
causes like heart attacks and strokes to sudden
ruptures of internal organs - including, in
some cases, every major organ in the body
rupturing at once.
If only one person has currently viewed SCP-689
and is alive, the statue will cause their
death and immediately appear atop their body.
But when there is more than one possible target,
the statue becomes far more dangerous.
This effect only works on humans, but anyone
who has ever viewed the statue is vulnerable.
It’s as if it keeps a list of everyone who
has ever seen it and broken eye contact, and
when it has the chance, it starts picking
people off that list.
And it doesn’t matter where in the world
they are located.
The statue has been shown to be able to teleport
long distances and appear on the body of someone
who might have viewed it years ago.
There seems to be no way to predict in what
order the statue will claim its victim.
However, a disturbing pattern of who the Haunter
in the Dark decides is next has emerged.
When the statue has choices available to it,
it seems to often target a victim who is in
a large crowd.
That means that in an instant, hundreds of
people could see the statue and become future
targets.
As every time an eye is taken off the statue,
it could teleport and claim another life,
this raises the possibility of a horrific
chain effect scenario, where the statue could
teleport endlessly and rack up a massive body
count in mere minutes.
Which is why the Foundation has become determined
that it never be seen again.
The cell holding SCP-689 is one of the most
secure in the entire SCP Foundation, because
unlike other Keter class objects, it gives
very little warning.
If it is seen, it can be gone in a second
with no way of knowing where it is.
And depending on how many possible targets
are out there, it could be anywhere in the
world.
That is why it is currently encased in a large
concrete chamber, surrounded by high-intensity
sodium iodide lights.
Each of these lights has a separate power
supply, so there is no chance of a total power
failure.
And for those tasked with keeping it safe,
it’s one of the hardest jobs in the Foundation.
Three people are on duty at SCP-689’s cell
at all times.
Two D-Class personnel are stationed inside
the chamber, and a Level 2 agent is stationed
in the control chamber.
The D-Class agents have one job - to never
take their eyes off the statue.
They can alternate breaks, but the statue
must never be allowed to be unobserved for
even a second.
And because each person who has seen the statue
is a security risk, the D-class agents are
equipped with instant-kill devices so they
can be terminated from afar rather than being
potential targets.
The Level 2 Agent, meanwhile, has a very different
job.
This is one of the most specialized tasks
in the entire Foundation, because the agent
must be either blind or equipped with a helmet
that completely blocks their vision, which
they must wear for their entire SCP-689 shift.
All control features in the chamber are designed
to be operated by someone without the ability
to see, and the operator is not to remove
their helmet under any circumstances - or
they risk termination themselves as a potential
security risk and escape vector.
But don’t worry, even if the statue still
manages to escape its chamber, the Foundation
has a plan.
Just don’t tell staff assigned to 689 what
it is.
In the event of a containment breach or failure
of the lights in the statue’s chamber, the
first priority is to terminate any D-Class
or Level 1 observers who may have been exposed
to the Haunter in the Dark.
This is to reduce potential targets, and while
higher-level staff will be retained in most
cases, this only goes for the first containment
failure.
The Foundation will then deploy a retrieval
team of blind agents or those wearing vision-blocking
headsets.
Equipped with echolocation tech, they’ll
partner with D-Class observers to track down
everyone who is known to have viewed the statue.
The statue will invariably appear and lead
to the death of one of these people, so knowledge
of these potential targets is key to containment.
Then comes the challenge of returning it to
containment.
As soon as the statue is located, a perimeter
is established with coverings put up to avoid
any outside viewers catching a glimpse of
it.
The D-class observers enter the perimeter
and are transported back to the facility together
to ensure it never falls out of sight until
it is safely back in its chamber and its containment
protocols are put back in place.
But what is actually known about this deadly
statue?
Because of how dangerous and fast-moving the
statue is, any attempts to study its properties
must be approved by the presiding scientist
and are carefully scrutinized.
The curiosity to figure out its mysteries
is always tempered by the fact that any scientist
interested may be subject to summary termination
should it breach containment again.
Its origins are unknown and but it is thought
to be at least several centuries old, and
its form is believed to be based on a God
of the underworld.
This would explain its one function - ensuring
people make a swift visit to the afterlife.
It does not seem to have any direct hostility
towards humans or SCP personnel and has not
given any indication that it is sapient or
intelligent, but it does seem to want to spread
as quickly as possible - and it may be able
to sense where its best targets with the greatest
potential to spread are located.
This has led many to compare it to one of
the SCP Foundation’s most notorious residents.
SCP-173 is another statue that poses a grave
danger to anyone who looks at it the right
way.
Similar to SCP-689, it is frozen in place
and requires anyone who enters its containment
unit to look directly at it.
Any breaking of eye contact can be deadly,
and its more strict in its definition of breaking
eye contact than 689 is.
Simply taking your eyes off it for even a
second, even to blink is enough to seal your
fate.
But SCP-173 doesn’t use supernatural powers
to claim its victim.
This large concrete statue instead becomes
mobile and extremely violent when eye contact
is broken, killing its targets by strangulation
or breaking the neck.
While this entity has killed many personnel
since its containment, it doesn’t seem to
have the same ability of SCP-689 to teleport
to a completely different location, which
means it is actually less of a threat than
the Haunter in the Dark.
But the two statues’ similar MO of killing
when eye contact is broken has led some to
speculate a connection - despite one being
of modern construction and the other being
old, possibly even ancient.
But only one of these statues poses a potential
end-of-the-world scenario.
Which is why the Foundation is so concerned
about SCP-689 breaching containment.
SCP-689 might just be among the hardest anomalies
to get back in the bottle once it escapes.
If it appears far outside containment, in
a crowded scene, it now has hundreds of new
potential targets.
By the time the Foundation tracks it down
to its past location, it will have likely
teleported again - and there seems to be no
limit to how many lives it can claim in a
set time.
That means that as it racks up more targets
and teleports into crowds, it could escalate
into a major threat to Earth’s entire population.
With SCP-689 seeming to be able to kill anything
that breaks eye contact with it, there are
some in the Foundation who wonder if it should
be used against the most notorious captive
of the SCP Foundation - SCP-682.
This rage-filled, indestructible, regenerating
beast has been a thorn in the Foundation’s
side for years.
It has cost countless lives of agents and
personnel with its many containment breaches
and so far the Foundation has been unable
to terminate it by any conventional means.
But SCP-689 isn’t exactly what you would
call “conventional means.”
It simply triggers an invariably fatal reaction
within the body of whoever it targets - which
means it could possibly be the only thing
that could kill SCP-682 permanently.
The risks of pitting these two anomalies against
each other are immense though.
Not only does any interaction with SCP-682
carry risks of yet another catastrophic containment
breach, but moving the volatile SCP-689 puts
everyone, not just those in the Foundation,
at risk too.
The proposed plan involves exposing the two,
then immediately turning off the lights.
But for this experiment to be pulled off safely,
every personnel who has seen SCP-689 must
either be terminated or placed in the same
containment chamber - giving the statue no
choice but to eventually choose SCP-682.
To improve the chance of success, the doctors
planning this operation have suggested terminating
all D-class personnel in advance to better
the odds.
Should this experiment ever be approved though,
a failure could be truly catastrophic.
SCP-682 has already shown itself able to come
back from things that are seemingly impossible
to survive, including having the majority
of its body destroyed with only atoms remaining,
and yet it was still able to regenerate back.
Who’s to say it couldn’t survive a heart
attack or organ rupture too?
There is also the risk of 682 gaining the
power used against it.
The only thing worse than SCP-682, is an SCP-682
that can now teleport around the world to
kill anyone who has ever looked at it.
But even with these risks, the experiment
has not been officially ruled out.
Could one of the Foundation’s deadliest
Keter class anomalies be the solution to another?
It’s under advisement, but for right now,
the Foundation is keeping a very close eye
on SCP-689 - in more ways than one.
For more on the Foundation’s first killer
statue, check out “SCP-173 - The Sculpture
Tale”, or watch “Termination Attempts
SCP-682” for just how hard this lizard is
to kill.